Hey, what's going on? It's
built burn. It's the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
July 28th,
2014 what's going on?
Hi,
how's it going?
I just got back from Oriol Canada
doing the wonderful a Montreal comedy
festival. I had an awesome time up
there. I hosted one of their Gallus,
you know, which is a big deal. And uh,
you know,
I'm not big on hosting,
I'm not big on hosting cause I hit my
bitch are long and it's sort of like,
I don't really know how to write a joke.
So there's a lot of cursing and making
faces and I built momentum off of that,
so I just keep fucking roll in with that.
And before people realize that
they've listened to an hour,
my shit and I get out of there,
but if I host,
I got to keep coming back out and I got
to get that energy going again. And um,
you know, it's fucking exhausting.
So, uh, to be honest with you,
I didn't want to do it, you know, see
probably like we'll build and why the,
why the fuck did you say? Yeah,
I'll do it. I'll tell you why.
Because I bought the money pit house.
That's why
I am out there whoring myself.
I'm gonna tell you right now,
cause I was going to take
the whole fucking summer off.
I was going to take the rest of July and
August off cause I toward like fucking
18 months straight at a all over this
great global fucking marble and I was just
like, look, I'm taking two months
off, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Right. I was going to have a great fucking
time. I'm bringing it barely back. Yeah.
And I was just going to
fucking chill out and grill.
I was going to sit on
my fucking back porch.
I was going to stare off into the fucking
half a yard that I have out here in
La, which is actually
considered a decent yard.
Do you know you can't throw a Frisbee in
my backyard without hitting something?
I mean it right as it leaves your hand.
It probably,
if I go the long way,
I decide I could maybe float
for just under three seconds.
It's not really a yard. I have
an area. All right, whatever. Um,
I live in a metropolis, so anyways, um,
yeah, so I was going to take the
whole summer off and you know,
as these guys finished this one
thing that they were going to do,
the area that got damaged
by the fucking water, and
this is what I learned when your house
is fucking like a hundred years old,
90 years old,
whatever this thing is,
it's just you have 90 fucking years.
Well,
let's say the first 10 years,
everything's going pretty smoothly.
About from about 80 years
in all the way back,
80 all the way up to right now you just
have one do it yourself fucking job.
Hey, I've got a guy, I got a,
Hey, I'll do it for nothing, man.
It's a 1930. Say there's a
d, there's no code. Nothing.
Okay.
Now when I tell you nothing,
I mean nothing,
nothing downstairs in
my house was up to code.
Nothing. I know what you guys
are thinking. Like, well wait,
didn't you get somebody doing spec
the house when you bought it? Yeah,
but they can't see into the fucking walls.
Okay?
You have no idea what's in you all,
they can just look at it.
You know they're looking for fucking sweat
marks on the walls smelling for water
damage check and the gas
lines. They can do that. Right.
But other than that,
you're pretty much on your own.
And I'll tell you all you guys
fucking listen to right now.
If you laugh and you have no idea
what the fuck's in your walls,
you have no idea what some Douche bag did
20 years ago cause he bought the time,
life books,
those do it yourself fucking things.
And you have no idea what that
can't rewired in your wall.
Okay.
Under your floorboards.
I mean, so basically
downstairs is laid open at this point,
like at seven open heart surgery. Okay.
And every time they think they got to
the last thing, there's another thing,
I know what you're thinking.
Built these guys downstairs to taking you
for a ride. Oh yeah, I'm sure they are.
But what that finding is fucking
undeniable. Do you know we,
they got to this wall the other
day and of course, you know,
it's got this shit fucking rotted out,
crap in front of it. They get rid of that.
We get underneath that,
we get behind that and at the
base board it's just dry rot.
The guys barely touching it and it's
not like it's, it's breaking off.
It's turning into powder.
Like fucking long.
Chaney junior put this board in when
he was a struggling fucking actor.
That's how old this goddamn houses
and showed. They're like, yeah,
we've got to rebuild this wall. Costs
like four or 500 bucks am I God ride,
just fucking do it. Right. So
they take down the drywall,
plastic,
whatever the fuck it is and you know,
later on that date, right, I'm, I'm
running around doing, I'm around,
I'm doing and the contractor calls me up
and he's actually laughing. He's like,
Bill, you eat it. You got to
come over and see and see this.
And I'm taking in my fucking head like,
dude,
this isn't whatever you laughing about.
This isn't funny.
And I got over there and
basically behind the wall
is like this dirt, right? They have
like a, you know, this crawl space area.
And what they had behind the wall
is somebody had taken like this,
see through like plastic tarp,
and that was the,
that was the barrier between the dirt
and the wall was this plastic fucking
thing. And the guy was laugh
and go, Ha, you got to tell you,
I've never seen anything like this,
which he probably has.
But, uh, you know, I
know I'm just a comedian,
but I know that that's not the way you're
supposed to do something like that.
But the good thing is that
is the final wall downstairs.
And of course it couldn't have been,
it couldn't be built. Right, right. So
in other words,
I want to be doing some shows on the odd
ball toward this later on this summer.
Ah, fuck. I swear to God,
and this is the thing too.
I could have been a cunt. I could have
been like, dude, I don't give a shit.
Just put a fucking wall in front of
it and fuck the next guy. But, uh,
that's not the way I'm wired or
what are you a hero now, Bill?
Now I was raised properly fixed the
thing, right. Just fix the fucking thing,
right.
Cause I'm not going to have you put a
beautiful brand new wall in there with
that fucking a sandwich bag
barrier behind it. And then what?
I Dunno what happens seem to be working
all right before they cut open the wall.
I'm sorry. I'm fucking,
I, I've, I've had it.
I've had it with the goddamn downstairs.
Um, so that's what's going on.
So if you hear drilling and you'd be here,
all kinds of shit going on.
That's the fucking people
downstairs. And uh, we're hoping,
we're hoping that they're
going to be done. You know,
initially it was end of June,
beginning of July. Now, uh,
I don't even ask anymore.
Last I heard was end of August,
early September and come on
and I'm hoping by Thanksgiving I can
actually walk down there and my fucking
slip us, you know, we won't
have any money for a Turkey.
I'm going to shoot a fucking pigeon and
I'm going to deep fry it and I'll do it
the wrong way.
I won't take into consideration the
space that the pigeon is going to take up
and a the grease, we'll go over and I'll
like the whole fucking thing on fire.
We'll start over again.
Oh God.
Oh Jesus. This is why I
actually like going on the road.
I liked going on the road because I
don't have to listen to the sounds.
That's the sound of the money
flying out of your bank account.
How? Um, all right, so I had,
I had an unbelievable week, uh,
aside from I'm going up to Montreal,
Montreal comedy festival and seeing
a bunch of great comics. Um, guys,
I started with people who started before
I did and then a bunch of new faces
that I went down and checked out.
Um,
earlier this week I did a show out
here in la that I mentioned last week.
I was talking to Norton
Warner. I was gonna, it's gonna
play drums with his band.
They had this cool show, like best
goddamn comedy. Show us something, uh,
hosted by Josh Adam Meyers.
Um,
and uh, we basically, uh,
hang on a second. What the fuck is
this now? Getting this fucking text?
Come on. It's just, you know what,
this is one of these days, like,
I should just,
I have to get into the right mindset
because it's all going to just
fuck all right. Anyways, plowing ahead.
Josh. Adam Meyers hosts his show.
He's got a band and basically, and I
was a bunch of comics that play guitar.
Are they saying are they play drums or
whatever and you basically, you go up,
you do standup,
you do whatever you want,
but you can kind of make it music
based and then in the end you a,
you interact with the band however
you wanted to do it. So, uh, you know,
I was like, all right, I'll play
drums, will play a Zeppelin song.
And I was kinda thinking like I,
if I just go back there,
I can't remember if I
told this story last week.
I know I told you guys that I was
going to do it, but basically I'll,
I'll fly through it here. I
basically was thinking, all right,
well if I just go back and play drums
and I do a decent job that will be
interesting for like 30 seconds and
then people will have to sit through the
rest of the song. So, um,
like a year ago I was going to
dress up like John Bonam for a,
for Halloween and I, they,
I ordered the tee shirt,
a remake of the tee shirt that he wore
on now that that concert
film song remains the same.
And I had the blue Adidas dragons.
Turns out he was wearing a four
stripe Adita when he was in Seattle.
And then I had the white pants.
I went out and bought those and my wife
took me to a costume store and we got
the fucking wig and the, the led Zeppelin
one mustache that he had, you know,
I was like a big thing with [inaudible]
with like how long it took for his
mustache to connect into his beard because
his mustache wouldn't connect it to
the beard. And for the first, like three,
four albums, he had that beard that was,
that went like underneath his chin,
like a fucking Chin strap.
Like he had nothing up there on his face.
And you know what's sad is by the
time his mustache and beard connected,
it's like he died.
It was like his life's work was complete.
Um, so anyways, um, well I'll post some
pictures if you follow me on Twitter.
I already posted a few, but
I'll, I'll repost them for, uh,
for people who have lives and
are not on Twitter. But anyway,
so I went back there. I had
a great fucking time. We
screwed it up quite a bit.
We butchered it pretty good.
But um, but it was still
funny, man. It was a fun time.
And,
uh,
and for the longest time I was kind of
looking for a way that I could actually
play live drums and people would know
that I wasn't taking myself too seriously.
Um,
and going up and dressing up and looking
like an idiot was kind of the perfect
way to do it.
And it also Kinda gave me licensed slur.
I didn't have to feel self conscious that
people were looking at me cause I had
this whole fucking get up
on with the sunglasses. I
could kind of hide behind it.
It was actually pretty,
uh, it was pretty cool.
So I'm definitely going to do another one.
I'm trying to a,
I think I already know the song I'm going
to do when the drama that I'm going to
dress up like, and uh, I dunno,
it's going to be a great time.
It's gotta be a great time on the show.
We'll get big and then somebody's network
will come down and they'll turn it
into a TV show and then they'll ruin it
and they'll take all the fun out of it.
So I'll let you know when the next one is.
Uh,
so before people come in and try to
figure out how they're going to make money
off of it,
it's going to be a great time.
So I'll let you know when
the next one is and she,
you should definitely come down now
as we're on the beginning of the,
behind the music arc on
this idea. Uh, but anyways,
but thanks to everybody in the band and
Josh and everybody for having me come
down. I had a fucking awesome
time. So, and with that,
so that was my Monday. And
um, and then like I said, uh,
I went up,
what was it,
a Thursday I flew up to Montreal,
one of my favorite cities with, uh,
the team. I don't like the most,
the fucking Canadians. I don't mind
him. Whatever. Um, oh you know what,
PK sue band came down to one of the gals.
I thought he was coming down to my gal.
I was really excited to meet the guy cause
I wanted to ask him about that whole,
uh, cause it really seemed when, you know,
Sean squirted the water in his face,
like we had them and then they did that
and then they just fucking rallied and
they won game six and seven.
I just,
I was dying to hear what the
fuck he had to say on that.
And of course he was at
another gala. Um, oh, well.
So anyway, so I went up to
Thursday and, um, landed,
got over and did this show.
Uh,
Paul presents as a green room and it
was like sort of this remembering, uh,
all the great comics who've
passed. Uh, it was, uh,
you know, Patrice
Schimmel, Greg Geraldo, uh,
John Pinette, you know, Mitch Hedberg
and on and on and on and on and on.
And we told a bunch of funny
stories and gave each other shit.
I guess people enjoyed
it. Um, Robert Schimmel,
I don't know if I said him and, uh,
yeah, if it was a, it was actually,
it was a good time. Um, even
though I was dreading it,
it actually turned out
to be a really good time.
But then afterwards somebody mentioned
that we forgot to bring up auto and
George Auto in Georgia. And I was just
like, oh man. So I felt bad about that,
but either way, she
started off well and, um,
and then just every night
and the Versie and, uh,
Tony v the Great Tony v ended up at
a cigar bar every night at the end,
smoking Cuban cigars. And, uh,
I gotta be honest with you,
I was done after two nights. I can't smoke
a cigar three nights in a fucking row,
but Versie is a fucking animal.
And by the third night,
Tony Vee had gone back. So it was
just me and versing. I actually,
I get like a small one. And even then
I feel like, I feel like I've stood,
I stood behind a bus. Like usually I buy
a box of Cubans and I bring them back.
And at this point I didn't even
want him. It's like, I need to,
I need to take time off of this shit.
It's just too much.
So, um, I think I'm on the wagon again.
You know, I do it. I either, I
don't know how to, I even fucking,
I'm going to have 20 them and
fucking cigars every night,
or I just say fuck it for like 60, 70
days. That's it works for me. All right.
Just go fuck yourself with
your role in, uh, your eyes.
Yeah.
Can't help it.
If I don't have any willpower.
Actually I do have willpower
the 70 days and then I'm good.
Um, but I want to thank Tony Vee, Tony
Vee. Um, I went up there and they were,
they had this award show thing and they
were giving out these awards for comedy,
which is silly, but, uh, you know,
what are you going to do?
They've done a bunch of shit for me.
It was anybody else that would have
been like, no, no, I don't want to go,
you know what, I'm working,
but some aren't comedy fest.
Who doesn't want to go to Montreal?
So I went up there and I had Tony v do
the intro when he fucking absolutely
crushed it.
Um,
okay.
And, uh, that was, that
was, that was a great time.
And then the next night I did
the gala and a I got to give a,
I gotta give a shout out to, to the
people that were on the show. Man,
they were great.
This dude mocks for what,
who I worked with in
Toronto was hilarious.
And we had worked in Toronto like the end
of last year when I saw growth in him,
like major growth since the last time
I was with them. He was fucking great.
God Damn. I hope I don't forget
anybody. Michael Che, um,
who I wasn't familiar with,
I made sure I went on youtube and I
watched everybody before I went out there
because that wasn't allowed to say he's
been on this show or this show because
we were up in Canada and I watched
his Letterman and she said the guy was
phenomenal. And then his jokes
at the Gallo or even better,
uh, shit, I'm getting old. Oh.
Versie Versie was on the show.
Uh,
Nikki Glaser.
She was on it.
MMM.
Was that all day on the show is literally
two days ago. Oh. And then Chris Delea,
he comes out absolutely fucking
murders it. He's a based,
and then dom Irrera walked out.
Closed it out.
Yeah.
Oh wait, uh, um,
Kurt Metzger,
how much said Bert Kreischer,
that's how fucking old and Kurt Metzger
came out. He did this fucking bit.
And what killed me was the,
the,
I don't want to ruin the joke
because I don't want to do his bits,
but he did this bit and he was so
clearly being absurd and it was fucking
hilarious. It was, it was
a bit about, you know,
girls in their teens committing suicide
and he had a solution as to what to do
to prevent them from not killing
themselves. And it was fucking hilarious.
It was absurd. But the, the,
the reviewer was just like,
it didn't go over well at the gala.
It did go well on the nasty show.
It's like, yeah, that's not
his fault. You fucking idiots.
Do you think he's being serious?
That there's nothing that gets all the,
a lot of shit gets me gold,
but that really fucking annoys me when
the critic doesn't even get the joke.
And then blaming the comedian,
whatever.
All right.
So he fucking killed.
Okay.
Though everybody, the whole fucking
show was great. The show was great,
and I was actually, uh, I was dreading
doing it because, like I said,
I was hosting and that was
outside of my comfort zone. Um,
you don't wanna you know what it is?
It goes back to early in my career
where I hosted a show at the comedy
connection in Providence,
Rhode Island,
and I ate my balls so fucking bad.
And the thing about it is,
is if you're just doing a set,
if you go up and bomb is bad as it is,
you're tearing that you're tearing the
bandaid off. Whatever you're doing,
you know, in 10 minutes you're
getting it over with. You're doing,
it's going by in real time.
If you're hosting,
you go up and eat your balls, you
get off, you got to go back up again,
bring up the next, each your balls,
bring up the next guy, go back up again.
You just have to keep
going back up and in.
It's not like you get to start over
again. They're like, oh yeah, that guy,
that guy that we don't like.
And it just keeps going on and
off for the duration of the show,
which is gonna be be at least 90 minutes.
So for 90 minutes,
you're eating your balls,
even when you're not up there eating it,
you're in the green room dreading
and you're making a set list.
What if I did this joke?
Freaking the fuck out. Uh,
so I think that I actually have a,
uh,
I have a phobia or I did anyways. I had
a phobia fucking hosting and that, ah,
that got rid of it.
You see that when you've got dry rot
on the bottom of your fucking house,
you can get over there. A lot of fears.
All right, let's get into the, uh,
the advertising for this week.
Everybody, um, stamps.com quick,
convenient, and most
importantly, easy to use.
That's how I would describe stamps.com.
It will make your mailing and shipping
a breeze. Oh, for fuck's sakes.
Hold on a second. This construction
people, hold on. Hold on. God dammit.
All right. I'm back. Jesus fucking Christ.
Can we shut off the water for just an
hour? There you go. Let me ask, what was
the old, she's all right.
Where was I? All right.
With stamps.com buy and print official
US postage using your computer and
printer.
There's nothing to learn.
stamps.com will give you a digital scale
and automatically calc calculates exact
the exact postage for any letter,
any package.
They'll even help you choose the best
class of mail to get your mail on time for
the least amount of money.
Then drop your mail into any mailbox or
hand it to your mail, man or mail lady,
and you're done. You'll never have
to go to the post office again.
Everybody trusts me. Mailing and shipping
has never been easier. Right now,
use my last name. [inaudible],
B U R, r for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer offer
that includes a digital scale and up
to $55 free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr. All right. Dollar
Shave Club. Everybody.
The big razor companies
think we're stupid.
Every year they roll out some
ridiculous shaving technology gimmick,
right and x and expect us to
shell out our big bucks for it.
Do you really need to raise
it with a vibrating handle?
How about a roller pivot
ball? Backscratcher egg timer,
laser point a corkscrew.
You get the point. You don't
need it. I know I don't.
We were shaving just fine before any of
that junk and I definitely don't need to
spend my hard earned cash on it.
Um,
if you're sick of being
treated like an idiot,
join the hundreds of thousands of
smarter people who joined the dollar.
Shave club.com revolution.
Dollar Shave Club delivers the best blades
and grooming supplies for just a few
bucks a month.
Their blades are better than
the big shaving companies
for fraction of the price.
It's perfect.
They deliver them right to your door.
You'll always have a nice sharp blade.
I wish they had this when I was a kid.
My listeners can get started
now@dollarshaveclub.com
slash spur and hey,
if you're already,
if you're already a member,
you got to check out their new Dr Covey,
post shave lotion.
It's the perfect way to make peace with
your face after the disruptive act of
shaving. By the way, after shaving
lotion, lotion, underrated,
underrated,
you gotta use this stuff.
Stop getting ripped off by
the big shape companies.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
And lastly,
but not leastly on this little ad chunk,
prosper lending in 72 hours,
you could have $35,000 to cover
your needs. What will you do?
Pay Off hike rate credit cards.
Start a business.
Do that home improvement project
to [inaudible] host, um, ad.
Um, I'm the worst. That
was me. Add something you'd
like to do with that money.
I know what I'd like to do.
I'd like to pay an extra crew
to finish off downstairs. Um,
with our sponsor prosper. It's
never been easier. Go Online,
answer a few questions and see how
your low fixed rate. Wait a minute.
Slow Down Bill.
Go Online,
answer a few questions and see
your low fixed rate in seconds.
Your money hits your account in as few
as three days and as few as three days.
A prospers,
prospers the fastest growing peer to
peer lender and they facilitated over $1
billion in loans to people like you.
They're revolutionary platform connects
people looking to borrow money with
those who are, um, have money to invest.
There's no outrageous fees,
no raising interest rates,
and you'll never set foot in a bank.
Just go to prosper.com/ [inaudible] r
to check your rate instantly without
affecting your credit score.
That's nice for a limited time prosper
is offering my listeners a $50 visa
prepaid gift card.
When you get the loan,
go to prosper.com/burr up to $35,000
in just three days and a $50 gift card.
Go to prosper.com/birth all right,
here we go.
Back to the thing there.
You know,
one of these weeks I'm actually going to
look at the copy before I go to read it.
I always do that personal experience.
So I go host.
Okay,
what a Maroon. Um, all right. So anyways,
so now that I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm trying to convince myself that
I'm going to knock off the drinking.
Whenever I quit booze,
I have to go like six days.
I can go like three, four days and I
don't give a shit if I have a beer.
But once I get to six days, I feel like
I got a little hitting streak going,
you know, and I don't want to
start back over at zero. So, uh,
we'll see how I am this time next week.
But I'm going to lay off the stove,
going to lay off the booze there.
And I'm like, I said, we'll, we'll, we'll,
we'll see how it goes and I'm trying to
do my final push to tip the scales at a
buck 62. The last time I
had a flat stomach and a
little bit of abs over there.
And, uh, I got to be honest, you,
a lot of people are giving me shit for
my diet advice despite the fact that I
know some people that have been,
you know,
some of the suggestions that I'm making,
keen was salads and all that type of
stuff. Somebody actually texted me saying,
your diet advice is making me angry.
It's just like, dude, I think that
has less to do with what I'm seeing.
I'm suggesting vegetables,
vegetables are making you angry.
I think that has to do with
you probably at, you know,
an overbearing father like myself.
You know,
we didn't let you speak up
and express your opinions.
You could just write me and
just say, hey, you know,
why don't you try this instead
of sitting there stewing,
um, no pun intended. And then
there's other people that, you know,
you're giving me shit just saying that
veggies or for rabbits and all of that,
that all of that usual shit. I never said
don't eat meat. I'm just saying, I just,
what's been working for me,
I'm in the best shape.
I've been in like three years and
everybody's saying my dietary advice,
advices bullshit. It's, it's
completely working for me.
And they're still holding on to that
whole like, you know, we like a mad,
you know,
fucking go kill an animal and go eat it.
I'm not saying don't do that
Shit, but, uh, here's something.
Here's something.
Uh,
I would like you to try for all the meat
eaters out there that had given me shit,
and I'm not even saying this,
so fucking paranoid carnivores.
I'm not even saying don't eat
meat. I'm just saying, you know,
twice a fucking week. This is what
I do with the veggies over there.
And they get in the backs up again,
not freaked out. Let me ask you this,
this steak dinner. I want you
to do a experiment, all right?
One night,
go out and get yourself a lovely,
amazing steak dinner with the baked
potatoes and the cream has spinach in your
glass of wine and all of that.
And I want you to honestly tell me how
you feel afterwards. I know you feel full,
I know you feel great,
but I want to know how long after that
meal before you just have to lay down and
go to sleep, which is
basically your body going, wow,
look at this fucking mountain
of work we got to deal with.
Let me just go fucking lie down.
That's shut the body down so we can
get this through our fucking system.
If you go out and you have a
fucking Veggie dinner, right.
That's of of the same quality
of as a good steakhouse. I mean,
I'm not talking about going to one of
those things where they deep fry fucking
Zucchini at that point you
might as well go to Mcdonald's.
I'm saying actually a really,
you know,
like comparable to whatever
steakhouse you going to go to,
a comparable vegetarian place. And
uh, tell me how you feel after that.
Okay. And I will always eat steak.
I love a fucking steak dinner.
I love chicken. I love all of that shit.
I'm always going to eat that stuff. But,
um,
it's undeniable as far as I'm concerned,
how much better I feel
when I do the veggie thing.
So I know I'm never going
to stop eating cattle,
so I just look at it kind of
like what the Stovies, Hey,
I just take a break for a couple of days.
That's all I'm suggesting. All right,
so all you guys who were sending me
homophobic shit suggesting that I now want
to lay down with another man just cause
like want to have a fucking Q Columbo.
Well, don't look at the shape of it. Q
comp was like a fucking porn stars Dick.
You know,
it's like you're blowing the hall.
Um, anyways. Hey, this
is a great time with Eo.
It's actually getting a little
late, you know, I hope you got you.
I forgot to bring up again once again
to have yourself a little veggie garden.
You know, our tomatoes are just starting
to become ripe and the other night, okay,
one of them fell off
the branch there and uh,
we cut it up, put a little salt and
pepper drizzle a little olive oil,
made it a little,
I guess less healthy fucking eight.
The thing I was unbelievable.
Unbelievable what a tomato was actually
supposed to taste like versus what the
fuck you usually get. Um, so anyway,
so all you guys out there who think
I'm like, you know, slowly gonna Start,
you know, walking on stage
wearing yoga, stretchy pants.
Um, I mean I might have to
do that one night if, uh,
if you know that, that uh, Josh is,
show them the best God damn comedy show,
whatever the fuck he calls it,
you know?
Okay.
Depending on what drummer I'm
dressing up, like, I mean,
if you look at a lot of the hair
metal and that type of stuff,
some of that spend x,
I mean,
they were basically wearing yoga
pants that were shorts, right?
Is that what it was?
I want to do a Stryper song joke and
I would never do that to people. Um,
anyway, so that's all I'm
suggesting so everybody can,
uh, you know, fucking relax.
You can relax.
Um,
what else did I do up in Montreal
besides booze? My face off.
Oh,
I did radio and did some radio.
He did a rich and Bonnie's
podcast going in there,
knowing full well that it was going to
be some of the most awkward moments in
the history of, of radio, which
is basically what a podcast is.
I don't know why they call it a
podcast. It's a fucking radio show. Um,
what is this podcasting, how
would you describe it? Well,
have you listened to the radio? It's
that, except it's on the Internet. Hmm.
Interesting. Um, so if you've
never listened to the, uh,
rich and Bonnie podcast, my
wife hates me. Uh, uh, I,
I would highly recommend it.
And I went on this thing knowing that
it was going to be brutal. And uh,
and then me and Bonnie, we, we got this
fucking thing where we like each other,
but our conversations do not link up.
You have to have somebody like that,
somebody you just, you
just cannot, like you just,
it's just been a 20 year
misunderstanding between the two of us.
I never know what she's saying.
She never knows what I'm saying and it
just leads us to these fucking dead ends.
We'll,
we just both looked at each other,
shake our heads and walk away and then
start over again at the top of the street.
So that's essentially,
if you'd like to listen to like an hour
of that with rich vos telling stories
that really have nothing to do with what
me and Bonnie are attempting to say to
one another. I highly recommend
it too. I'm, I'm fucking around.
It was a great time. Uh,
people really seem to enjoy it.
And then also there was some really
funny comics in the crowd. Um,
Judy Gold, uh, you know, people like
that Shyman in and that type of stuff,
adding to it.
So,
and this one old guy who fell asleep
two minutes into it and we actually sent
him, sorry, she said the hiccups
there. I wasn't getting emotional.
We actually sent him off into the corner
so he could sleep and his friends could
watch. And a, he nodded
off for the whole show.
I think we got a picture of him.
Um, all right. And then that was it.
I did the opiate Jimmy show.
Okay.
And, uh, I think that that
was it. That's what it,
that's what I did.
That was my festival and another one.
Now the Montreal comedy festival
down enough fucking tubes.
Um, right. Hey, you know, don't look now,
but the New York Yankees are
making a push for the playoffs.
Those sons of bitches, they're
actually in the wild cad. And um,
as a fan of Derek Jeter,
I'd like to see them make it just to CG
to do one more post season. Of course,
I want to see the hankies loose,
which is always bigger,
is bigger than my respect for
Derek Jeter. But, uh, I don't know,
be kind of sad if that was like,
you know,
fuck it ended the season and then that,
that was just it.
I do have tickets to the uh,
okay
to that, that last game
he's playing at Fenway Park.
Did I tell you guys I bought in half
on red sox season tickets this year.
Buddy of mine was on a waiting list for
10 years and he got these great seats.
He's like, I can't, I can't swing these
man. I need some more people to buy in.
So I bought in for my
little block of tickets,
me and a couple of the guys or whatever.
And um, cause they're expensive as shit.
And I'm thinking like,
all right, well, you know,
I got enough family and friends back there
that I can sell them to them and then
I can, you know, the socks don't care if
you put them up on stub hub. So I'm like,
I'll, I'll, I'll be fine.
Right. And uh, you know,
the red sox shit, the bed from day one
and I can't give these things away.
I've lost,
I lost my shirt on these tickets
once again. Bill Borough and the comedy
odd ball tour later on this summer.
Um, Jesus fucking Christ.
So, but I do have that,
you know what's funny is
I could actually sell the,
and I could sell that pair of tickets
on stub hub and I can make a ton of
fucking money, a ton of my
money back. I would still lose.
But especially if the Yankees don't make
the playoffs and that could actually be
like his last fucking game. I
think there's a possibility. Um,
uh,
this is a sports fan. There's no
fucking way I'd rather be there.
I've never been like, you know, I remember
a long time ago to two of my buddies,
they get season tickets to the patriots
in 1985 and the patriots ended up going
to the Superbowl and they had tickets
to go to Superbowl 20 and they both
scalped him and I just met him.
I thought it was the dumbest thing ever.
And even though we lost 46 to 10,
even though we got fucking destroyed,
it's just like I would,
I would still rather go to Superbowl 20
and actually see the 46 defense live.
You could've saw Walter
Payton, all of those. Uh,
you know, Richard Dent, Wilbur Marshall,
all of those fucking hall of Famers,
all of those people you
could have seen. I, you know,
Jim McMann versus fucking Tony Eason
and then old Steve Grogan coming in that
whole file, but it would've been great.
And you get to party down in New Orleans.
I definitely,
I always think the experience,
even if your team loses his better
than selling them, and maybe, uh,
maybe I'm a fucking jackass, but,
uh, I always look at it that way.
So I'm definitely going back,
um, for that game. You know,
maybe I'll pick up like a one
nighter along the way. Um, but,
uh, I'm really looking
forward to going to that. Wow.
So maybe I should be rooting for the
Yankees not to make the playoffs.
So that'll be his last game.
So actually it will be like,
and like the fucking bottom of the
eighth of the top of the ninth,
Derek Jeter coming up for
his final fucking at bat,
but if he hoped he hits a home run to
right field, like fucking Ted Williams,
you know, he's got it. Do
something. Um, so anyways, uh,
and football is right around the corner.
This is such an exciting time.
Is there anything more exciting than
when you suddenly start going to like
fucking training camp? The greatest
month of the year for me is September.
It's just like I always get depressed
at how fast the summer goes by.
And then when all of a sudden it's
September and it's football and the games
count in his college football and all
of that type of shit. It's just the,
it's the greatest. It's the fucking
greatest. I can't wait. I can't wait.
So I mean, what else am I going to
do for the rest of the summer hunt?
Go out and sunbathe over there.
All right,
let's get into some of your questions
here for the week. Uh, the flute, it says,
Bill, you took a hammering from a
lot of people on all fronts. Twitter,
Facebook and emails. Um, nine,
10 mentioned, Oh, 90%,
I guess mentioned anchorman. Other
suggests you youtube jazz flute players.
Listen, go fuck yourselves.
All right. First of all,
you guys who said when I said there's no
cool way to play the flute and then you
bring up anchorman.
He was mocking playing jazz flute.
He was making fun of it.
It's a fucking movie.
Do you think those flames were actually
real coming out of the end of it?
Do you think he really drank a
fucking drink out of the thing?
It was using it as a straw.
It was a joke. All right.
Um, and as far as jazz flute, let me
tell you something right now. I don't, I,
I'm not saying that there's not
virtuoso play. I don't want to hear it.
There's certain instruments that listen,
if you want to accompany like
some shit with the flute.
Absolutely.
All right?
But there's a reason why there's no
fucking flute players in the rock and roll
hall of fame and don't even bring up
that fucking ban. Howdo Pope, pope,
whatever that fucking guy
is that Jeff Tull guy.
I don't even want to fucking hear it.
He did not get into the rock and roll
hall of fame because of his flute playing.
It was the fucking rock
music underneath it. Okay,
so you can take your flute. Okay. Turn
it up sideways and shoved straight up.
Yo Carrie Dils. No. Um, yeah, no,
I stand by that. I stand by that. I
put the flute right up with the oboe.
Now if I go watch a, a classic, I
guess I was talking to like rock music.
All right. Even jazz,
you can go fuck yourself.
I'd much rather that trumpet has so
much more power. Saxophone, trombone,
all of that shit. I would when I
listen to that than the God damn flute.
Now you take a flute and Piccolo and
you stick that shit in a a sympathy,
sympathy as symphony.
I can listen to it then.
Then I find it an amazing a
company. Mint. If you had,
I came to any of the words
I'm trying to use right now.
If you fucking have 40
other fucking musicians,
okay. Helping to flesh out
all around a fucking flute.
I can listen to it. Or a
Piccolo. I can listen to that.
If you want to have one little movement
where you know you got some dreadful
fucking music and all is lost and all
of a sudden there's a rail light at the
top of the fucking tunnel and you want to,
you want to emphasize that with a little,
oh Ooh,
what is that up there kind of fucking
notes with a flute or a Piccolo that have
at it have at it, but I don't want to
listen to a fucking hour. That shit.
I stand by it. Fuck all you flew.
Play in fucking assholes out there.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought that that would
have become a controversy? All right. Um,
hey bill, when's your next special
going to be available on Netflix?
We are shooting for December 5th.
Um,
December 5th is going to be the release
date and I'm editing it right now and I
could not be happier with the
way that this thing looks. Um,
I can't wait for you guys to see it and
I am in the process of writing my new
hour and I come and right out of the
gate with just a rough one. You know,
um,
it's really just coming off as sexist
and I have to be honest because I can't
stand outside of myself.
I can't have like a Jesus Christ.
What are they ripping up downstairs now?
You know what I think they're doing?
I think they getting rid of,
it's, this is actually exciting.
I have all this galvanized
pipe in my house. Um,
and they fucking Yank because like I said,
it's been flayed downstairs and he can
see all of it and they're like, well,
we might as well change it now before it
bursts that he's put that fear in your
head, hey, we're building this
beautiful bathroom. But sure,
it'd be a shame if this shit buying
a wall burst. I mean, we can risk it.
And you're like, all
right, just fucking, dude,
I'm not gonna make any
money off this house.
I'm going to have to
fucking live to be 150
okay.
Christ.
Yeah.
The only good thing about buying a fucking
house is that if you want to change
something you can, you don't have
to clear it with the landlord.
But as far as making any
money off your house,
it's a fucking pipe dream and less, you
fucking start fucking over other people.
And when the market's hot,
you go in and you buy houses and
you do a half ass fucking job,
you have fast,
the whole fucking thing.
You don't even know what
the fuck you do doing.
That's why I hate show where
the leaf flipped this house.
I can't stand watching those
people who aren't caught.
Like they sit there and they'll
show the guy who bought the house,
he's trying to figure out how to use the,
the, the, uh, the sander or whatever to,
to Redo hardwood floors.
He doesn't even know what he's doing.
They're playing this silly music
and he does a fucking half ass job.
And then you watch these suckers come
in because what he did is all brand new.
So it's still holding together
and it hasn't fallen apart yet.
And he'd just watching these people
getting led off to fucking financial
slaughter. Sorry. Anyways. Um,
so this opening bit that I'm doing,
I can't tell if a
okay
if it's coming off sexist
or I just am sexist.
Um, the point of it is, is
not the, isn't the sexism,
but it's really coming off like that.
It's really been a,
especially up there in Montreal. Oh
Jesus. I opened with that at the gala.
I'm sure we'll edit that one
out. Um, so anyways, yeah.
The next one,
it's going to be a December
5th and also my comedy album,
um, is finally done. Finally went through
all the red tape with Carnegie Hall,
Finally got Them, press all
the, uh, the records press. Um,
I'm going to find out today,
I actually have them in my house.
I have to find out when I can sell
these things to you because they're also
going to be available in stores.
Um,
but the fucker is done and I think I'm
going to be doing a co release with a
Aziz Ansari on a third man,
third man records,
which is Jack White's label out of
on Nashville, Tennessee. So, uh,
that's a little teaser. That should
be coming up in the next, um,
I dunno when in the next month or
so. I hope. I'm really hoping. Uh,
I think they're finishing up diseases
album. So a, it's going to be pretty cool.
And once again I really want
to make the stresses okay.
The material that's on
my Carnegie album is,
um,
that was November of 2011 and when
I taped you people are all the same.
That was march of 2012.
So that's December,
uh,
January, February,
March, four months later.
So this was where my act was
at four months earlier. So
there's a ton of overlap,
which is why I wanted to put it out on
vinyl only because I wanted to document
that I actually got to
perform at Carnegie Hall,
but I don't want to
fuck any you guys over.
Were you thinking this is going
to go, oh my God, this is a,
this is going to be an hour of completely
different shit that I never heard of
it.
That's not what it is.
What you're going to hear is where my
act was four months before I recorded it.
So there is some different shit,
but I'd have to say at least
80% of it is the same, um,
jokes, ideas or whatever. And
granted I tell them differently.
I'm sure someone will
listen to and be like, Hey,
actually you look the way you did the
fucking jerk off joke at Carnegie better
than you did it in DC.
So there will be that.
But I'm letting you guys know that shit.
So I don't want to hear any
fucking crap from any of you.
Like I screwed you over.
I'm going out of my way to let you
know that this is what it is. But, um,
it's really, uh, you know,
to have a comedy album,
you know,
is pretty fucking awesome
and it's something that I
don't think this will be the
last time I do this. I
would like to try and, uh,
you know,
I have a couple of ideas where I could
put out just an hour of original shit.
Maybe just od on vinyl. That could be
a cool thing. We'll see. We shall see.
So I'm just letting you know that
that is a, I actually have them,
I just have to wait to figure out
when I'm going to sell it. But, uh,
every day that I don't,
it's closer to the holidays and it'll
make a wonderful gift. There you go. Oh,
Jesus.
What does that guy drilling down there?
MMM.
If any of the construction
people are working on my house,
so listening to my podcast,
I know you guys are doing a
phenomenal job. All right.
I'm just being a crabby cont okay,
so don't fucking not tighten
down the screws down there.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
You hear that?
Yeah. I don't even know. I didn't
want to know what the fuck that was.
Um, all right, let's plow
ahead here. Uh, dude,
he didn't call Shit.
Versie um,
dear bill.
Yeah,
Ooda Zelie Uber.
Uh,
I'd like to congratulate Paul Versey
when no one else in the world was saying
Lebron would go back to Cleveland.
He was the only one. Oh No, wait.
He wasn't,
in fact,
he didn't call it until one week before
the decision was made and plenty,
all in caps of other people had been
making that exact same prediction.
You can look at his Twitter feed or
listened to his podcast for proof.
Basically everyone was saying it.
It was either Miami, Cleveland,
or a few other teams
that had made phone call.
Does Paul know that guessing correctly
by picking one of four choices isn't
calling it Jesus Paul.
He had taken a pounding.
He acts like he's Sam fucking
Rothstein and he may any,
he made some,
some out of left field prediction that
Lebron was going to the raptors as
something. Here's the thing, I like
Paul. I think he's funny, but holy Shit.
Cool it on the calling it thing.
I can't even imagine having an
argument with him in person. Ah,
this is fucking hilarious. Paul, look at
this guy. This guy is sharing my viewer,
you. Uh, he seems like, you
know, it's funny, as Paul is
listening to this right now,
and I know he's got his head down with
his looking through his eyebrows going,
he gets fucking bullshit. I said it
to j law had Jay lie, I can say it.
I said it two fucking years ago to j law
had an a bar in Cleveland. Um, he goes,
he seems like the type of guy who does
that thing where he puts the tip of his
fingers together when he's making a
point now he definitely doesn't do that.
Then shakes his hands back and forth,
uh,
from his chest to the floor like an
Italian and Italian and do that annoying
thing where you look at someone else in
the group besides the guy you're making
a point to as if to say,
hey,
we're all together on this point I'm
making against this guy in front of me.
Am I right fellas? That's fucking, that's
hilarious. That's why I love Italians.
I love that they do that. He goes, all
due respect to Paul though. Great Guy.
Now that you took the piss out of him,
he goes,
he literally has to be the worst
poker player on the planet too.
I can't imagine him playing it
cool with anything but pocket aces,
watching Paul's face and Paul's face
alone during the whole process of him
chasing a straight would be priceless.
Um, I played poker with Paul.
Now he has, he has a great, uh,
he has a great poker face and then
he has a way of looking at you.
He's got this face when he's looking
at you to try to figure out if you're
bluffing, that actually
makes you laugh. Um,
all right.
Paul shot has been fired your way.
For those of you not listening to the
[inaudible] podcast, this is like, uh,
like the old rap battles where Paul's
going to have an answer song, um,
to this guy. He's going to defend
himself. So everybody listened to the, uh,
the Versie effect.
I will email this,
I will copy and paste this and I
will email it to him and maybe, uh,
maybe he can write back. And, uh,
the worst part of all of this is I'm
going to have to listen to him defending
himself first to me on the phone before
I listened to him do it on his podcast.
So I have to listen to them
do it twice. All right. Okay.
Quit drinking would rather be alone.
This next person says,
uh,
Mr [inaudible] embarrassment.
Sorry.
Um,
I thought since you've taken time off
from drinking that you'd be a good person
to talk to,
talk to and ask about this.
I'm 22 years old and after hitting the
bottle hard since early high school I
decided to take some time off after
it seemed to get out of control. Yeah,
I've been there. I said I'd been sober
for nearly five months at this point.
The thing is that since
putting up the bottle,
I've noticed I enjoy spending time
alone rather than with other people.
I still go out to bars and hang with my
buddies who drink and usually just end
up being the designated driver.
He says I have no problem with
people who can control their alcohol.
Just thought it would be a good
personal choice to take some time away,
but being sober slash the sober guy at
22 is pretty damn rough when everyone
else is getting shitty. Just wondering
if you had any insight on the matter.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
well I can actually relate even at
46 of being the sober guy because of,
uh, all the free time
that comedians have. Um,
we can kind of drink like we're still 22,
so I know how I'm
okay.
I Buy, I guess, you know, but I'm not 22,
so I guess there is an extra amount
of stress with that. But, uh,
I think what you're doing is a
great thing and a Hello Neil.
Um,
I think it's a great thing.
And um,
how do I put this? The w w when you,
when you go on a run of not drinking,
it's all about you.
Okay.
And what you want to do and
how long you want to do it. And
um,
I wouldn't give in to any like external
pressures as to when and where you start
drinking again.
Um,
I always find it funny when I'm not
drinking to go to a bar and watch,
basically everybody's slowly roofing
themselves and then just watch the
behavior.
And like I said,
I don't do it in a judgmental way because
it's more senate kind of observing
like, oh, this is how I was acting.
Um, it can definitely suck at night,
but there's nothing better in the morning
when you wake up without a hangover
ready to take on the world. And,
uh, I would think at 22 to do that,
it's pretty mature and you've
got a chance of meeting a,
your judgment on who you start dating
would probably be a lot better rather than
you're hammered and she's hammered and
you start the relationship off in this
cloudy area. Um, you might meet another,
you know, smart person your age, uh,
who's taken some time off herself. Who
knows, who knows. But as far as like, um,
if you feel impressed you
to start drinking again,
that's the wrong reason to start drinking
because everybody else is drinking is
not the reason to come back it.
But you know,
if you feel like you have it under
control and you know, you, you know,
or if there's an event coming
up and you're like, okay,
I'm going to drink it that and then
I'm going to meet at least shut it off.
But I gotta be honest with you, that's
a tough thing to do because I was like,
I'm going to drink when I went to Vegas
and then I was immediately and go back
on the wagon and I was able to do it for
four days and then it was like July 4th
weekend.
Then I have a bad a beer and then I've
just been kinda drinking ever since. But,
uh,
fortunately I drank so
much in Montreal that yeah,
that now I don't want to drink.
I think that I almost need to do that.
I got to hit like a wall where I
either make such an ass of myself.
It makes such a bad decision or just
do something that, uh, it, it's,
it's easy for me to kind of like
want to walk away from it. But,
uh, like I said, it's all up to you. You
don't sound like you're an alcoholic.
I mean from your fucking email. I
can't really judge it, but like I said,
what have do whatever you want
to do, but don't, don't go.
Don't start drinking again
because everybody else's,
I guess that that would be my advice.
Um,
okay.
All right.
Let me,
let me read the last of the
advertising here then I'll wrap it up.
Some other questions here. Uh,
all right. Legal, everyone. Uh,
most Americans don't have a will,
but why you don't want the court
dictating what you just pointed at me.
I know I got to do this. I'm
doing this during this break. Uh,
you don't want the court dictating
what happens to your property and minor
children.
So why procrastinate?
Most people say too expensive or
too time consuming. My answer.
Legal zoom.com too expensive legal
zoom makes, uh, makes prices.
What legal zoom, legal zoom is. Prices
just makes sense. I swear to God,
I'm dyslexic too.
Time consuming.
It just takes 20 minutes and legal zoom
guide you through from start to finish.
The service was developed by some of
the best legal minds in the country,
and they made it painless for you to
get the legal help you need. In fact,
helping people get legally protected
has been they're missing mission and
passion for over 13 years during national.
Make a will month.
Get special pricing on wills and
living trusts by entering burpee.
You are are in the referral
box at checkout. Again,
that discount code is burr.
It's national. Make a will month.
So don't wait. Protect your family.
Protect your future at legal zoom today,
legal zoom was developed by top attorneys
to provide self help services at your
specific direction. However, they are
not a law firm. Legal Zoom. Um, I'll,
legal help is furnished through
vetted independent attorneys,
legal zoom.com discount code
burpee you are are, and lastly,
but not leastly Hulu plus everyone.
You've probably tried
Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with
Hulu plus you can watch your shows,
uh, watch shows on your schedule.
I love this. By the way,
Hulu plus has all of your favorite
shows like cosmos, a space odyssey,
Bob's Burgers or undateable starring
Chris Delea and watch every episode of
shows like South Park,
the Cosby show,
doctor who a bunch more Hulu plus
works on your computer, smart TV, Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox.
Pretty much any streaming device you
already own and you should be blocking off
a day just to binge with Hula plus you're
in total control to stream these and
thousands more as much as
you want whenever you want.
Also get exclusive access to stream
this criteria and collected collection
movies and Hulu plus has all of them.
All movies and kids.
Shows our ad free to for only seven
99 a month. Get your shows anytime,
anywhere, but right now I'm offering
my listeners a two week free trial.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's
a whole extra week for absolutely free.
Please make sure you use
Hulu plus.com/bill so you
get that extended free trial
and so that they know that we sent you.
It helps us to keep the lights
on and gives you a better deal.
One more time for the extended free trial.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill.
Um, oh hey for that kid also who
was talking about not drinking. Um,
here's another thing
too, you know, at my age,
I see,
okay,
I see the results of a
abusing your body with booze,
drugs, food. People say food is a drug,
which I would actually 100% agree with.
Um, you see the results of it. And um,
unfortunately when I was up in Montreal,
I saw a couple of people that are my age
in 10 years older and they either look
the ones that took care of themselves and
kind of quit drinking and tried to eat
right and that type of thing.
They look great.
They still got the light in their eye
and then people who've been a, you know,
hitting it hard,
man,
it really catches up with you when
you get to be my age where it's like,
um,
you know,
I've been of legal drinking age
longer than I've lived when I wasn't.
You know what I mean? That tipping point
of like 42 years of age when you've, uh,
you know, and forget about underage
drinking that you've already been doing,
I could really, really catches up with
you. So what you're doing right now,
given your body a break when it's as young
as it is, is a phenomenal thing to do.
And, um, you know,
you could actually experiment steering
even more into a healthier lifestyle,
like learning how to eat a little bit
better because at 22, man, I mean,
you can fucking drink a 12 pack and eat
McDonald's late at night and wake up the
next day with a flat stomach. But
like, you're setting yourself up for a,
you know,
just basically being a human being is
no different than being an athlete.
It's just the timeline timeline
is stretched out a lot longer.
Like father time is going to get
all of us. But, um, you know,
those athletes who throughout their
career, early in their career,
took care of themselves,
have longer careers and if you'd like
to have a longer career, in other words,
a longer life, like doing what you're
doing is a great thing. So, uh,
I don't know, when you look at it that
way, there's really no peer pressures.
They're really peer pressure to,
to die sooner. Um, all right. Nia,
do you want to chime in on one of these?
Um,
you want to do dead?
Nancy did Nancy Dead Nazi GRANDPA,
can I say Nancy? You know hard.
They're laughing in England right now.
Fucking Nancy boy, uh,
breaking up for college.
Which one do you want it?
Do you want to do that?
You want to stay in your wheelhouse?
I'll come over here.
Who is short shorts.
All right.
That's really good about quitting
drinking. I'm not drinking this week.
Come a little closer. I'm not
drinking this week. I said okay.
That's a good idea. It is a good
idea. All right, here we go.
Breaking up for college.
Uh Oh yeah, look at that.
What is this? This is, this is, she just
picked up my hotel key for this weekend.
That's the w hotels that,
that's how they advertise their spa and
there's a girl on it wearing a bikini
sitting on luggage and
holding like a hatbox,
so fit Avec Avec Tara stiles.
Is she like a trainer there?
There's literally a picture of like
a half naked woman on your room. Key.
Yeah. I mean I said that a long
time ago. I did the w hotel.
Everything looks like it's been just on.
No,
they have all they have of that hung
over lighting and all of that type of,
see you're making a mistake. Lamps,
you know, very sexy. Now it's Hacky,
sexy, that aquarium lighting
that they have in all of it. I,
I've decided I'm done with them. I'm
done with them. I like those older stuff.
Your places with the good breakfast
bar. What? Some holiday sauce.
I say holidays, holidays,
Hollandaise, Hollandaise.
Yeah. Many times I've read that and
I still can't retain it. All right.
Breaking up for college.
Dear bill,
my girlfriend and I had been dating
for awhile throughout high school.
It's pretty much the relationship
I've always dreamt of.
Never really getting tired of each other,
no fighting,
similar views and tastes
a healthy amount of sex.
Sounds like a recipe and a healthy scope
as sex. Very supportive of each other.
However, we both graduated high
school and are going off to college.
She's going to a liberal arts school in
Philly while I'm staying in the state,
uh, to go to northern Arizona
University. We both agree that would be,
it wouldn't be healthy to try and
maintain a long distance relationship.
So we're spending these last few weeks
of the summer together and we'll break it
off when she leaves for Philly.
Oh Wow. Man, that sounds sad. Um,
I could sure.
High School, this is a person who
just graduated from high school. Yeah.
And they're talking about,
it's pretty much the relationship
I've always dreamt of since when?
Since you were five. Yeah. I mean,
no, it's, no, it's really nice,
but it's like how, how is someone
who's graduated from high school?
Like I'm in the relationship.
I've always dreamed of.
Like I didn't know that high school people
dreamt of relationships in a way that
they really understood.
Maybe this person does see.
One of the things when you
do these questions is it's
very easy to superimposed
where your head was at it,
but it's literally reads like somebody
who's like a 30 year old. It's like,
it's what I've always wanted.
There's like a healthy amount of sex
and we don't get tired of each other.
It's like this is the highest visit.
Someone who just graduated. You know what?
Actually see your point. They do
sound like they're 35 it's like, whoa.
When did you dream of having
this great relationship? All
right, well let's, let's,
let's, let's continue. Let's see what we
got here. I could very well symbol shit.
Oh, you think this is a bullshit?
Well, I dunno. It sounds
nice. I'm sorry. Let's let,
let's continue. I should, well,
I'm very gullible. You can get me.
I could very well see myself spending
the rest of my life with this girl.
But at the same times,
four years is a lot of time.
I'm Matzoh fucking marriage right there.
Everybody has that one couple that wins
best couple and then they got together
the freshman, sophomore year and they
just didn't know how to break up.
So then they continue on and continue on,
you know,
and then you see him at the
10 year reunion. Yeah, we
broke it off when last week.
Get on with their life.
Um,
I could very well see myself spending
the rest of my life with this girl,
but at the same time,
four years is a lot of time and
a lot can change in that time.
So I don't expect us,
I don't expect for us to hook up
again the second we graduate. However,
she's come to be one of my closest
friends and I'd like to maintain that
friendship and she agrees.
I want to watch her life unfold and watch
her inevitable inevitable success come
alive. Yeah. These very mature people,
whether we're romantically
involved or not.
While this will be a bit of a
damper on the beginning of college.
I know I'm going to have a blast.
My roommate is one of my best
friends from high school.
He knows how to deal with me and he'll
kick my ass to get back in shape if I
start getting mopey about this girl.
Uh, what's your take on the situation?
Any words of advice or
encouragement? Thanks in advance? Um,
all right. I would say, uh,
when you break up with somebody,
my thing has always been
when you break up with them,
you got to get away from him because as
much as you have this mutual agreement
or something like that,
one of you is going to meet somebody first
and then it's just going to be rather
than enjoying, oh, I met somebody
and seeing how that goes,
you're going to have to deal with the
fact that you're dragging somebody else
through it and they'll hear it in your
voice. You know, what are you doing?
Nothing. Is there somebody over there
they're going to figure it out. And,
uh, if she finds out before you, you know,
find someone before you and yeah, yeah,
yeah. Again, you can try to get a back.
I mean, I think, I think,
I think you guys suggest go cold Turkey
until you have your Thanksgiving break.
Personally. Maybe an email here, email
there. Uh, but I think you guys should,
you know, if you're going to break
up, you got to break up. I think
I'm Neil,
I'm actually sure I'm,
I'm still trying to understand exactly
what the question is because honestly it
sounds like from this email,
it sounds like you've got it figured
out perfectly to me. Cause we see,
we both agreed that it wouldn't be
healthy to try to maintain a long distance
relationship. So we're spending these last
few weeks of summer together. Uh, yeah.
I mean,
you're not going to be the only person
in college and Freshman Year of college
she was left their boyfriend or girlfriend
behind. That's a pretty normal thing.
So yeah, spend your summer together.
It's, it sounds like a movie actually.
You know, I've spent the summer together
and then you both go off and yeah,
thanksgiving break they'll probably see
each other and whatnot. But I mean I,
I honestly wouldn't put too much
pressure on either one of you to try to,
it sounds like you're both really amazing,
lovely people and that's really nice.
But yes,
you are going to meet other people in
college and the fact that you're being
really realistic about it
is, um, if you were to guess,
I don't really have much to say
about the guests so mature. I can,
that's why I'm sort of like
stuck. All right. You want
to go to dead Nancy? GRANDPA
Nazi. All right. So yeah, I
can hear you guys seem you got,
you got to figure it out.
Yeah, I don't really, there's
not really much else to say.
Well what about me? My, my
advice, what I'm saying he should,
he shouldn't stay in contact with her.
I don't, I don't think that
that's possible. I mean,
I don't think you should try
to continue a relationship.
Like let's try to like make it work.
You guys have already said
it's going to be too hard,
but to be friends and things,
I made it. Part of her blossoming will be
her blowing somebody else's. Some point,
I don't want to be crass,
but I don't think you want to see grass,
but you just talked about,
well,
you don't want to see those things
like blowing somebody. Listen,
there's a lot of colors in a sunset. Okay.
There's a lot of colors in the sunset.
You don't need to see
blossoming coloring of this.
Let's say you're really trying to make it
or sunrise, sunrise blossoming, sunsets,
the end. No, I think they, if,
if they're going to be
friends that they're going to
take, they're going to tax,
they're gonna email.
They're going to see each other's social
media activity like it's impossible not
to and someone may get jealous.
It's not impossible not to. You just
don't look at it. You cut it up.
Sound like he wants to cut it out because
they really enjoy each other. I don't,
I don't know.
Doing, I'm doing the exact
thing that I told you not to do.
I'm super imposing my thoughts.
The shift if we were to,
God forbid if we were to
break up or whatever, you,
you would never want to like
text me or like talks to me.
You just be like, no, of course, of
course I would, but like I, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be involved in it because
I know I know where that's going.
I,
yeah,
yeah, yeah. I don't, but I don't
think they should go cold Turkey.
Yeah. You'd meet some guy
like some guy named Roger,
Roger Roy and those are guys. Rick. Oh,
he's got a car. He's
awesome. Um, all right.
Dead Nazi grandpa dear Billy blowhard.
Uh,
there's been a strong,
a story going around in the news here
and other Philly story here in Philly for
the past few weeks that I
want to hear your opinion on.
I'm writing because I know you
were a big World War II guy.
I was for like two months when I was
reading and then I fucking gotten,
I know enough now I'm into fucking keen
Wa and then you became obsessed with
something else.
That's what bill does.
He gets really into something
and he's like obsessive about it.
And then he moves onto the next thing,
which is why I'm a comedian.
Why can't write scripts?
Because my mind works in bits to take a
little of information and then I go, Ooh,
there's a spider on the wall.
The thing is,
is that I gave you a hard time about
that all the time and I'm very similar to
that finally.
Okay. And following this.
Okay, I know you're big world.
Go to God and fall and following this is
weirdly made me feel sympathy for an ex
Nazi. So He's been following this story
and he feels sympathy for an ex Nazi.
He says.
Long story short,
there was an 89 year old man who had
served as a guard in switch when he was 17
his mother was born in the United States.
So after the war he moved
to the Philadelphia area.
He lived here under his original name.
Um,
and this is June,
I guess until June,
2013 there was a word missing there when
a Bavarian town passed a law allowing x
Nazis to be ex communicated
to Germany to face trial.
He was eventually arrested and charged
with the 158 counts of accessory to
murder.
There was a big argument about it.
The guy just died in US prison this week.
I got into an argument about this today.
Is it fucked up for this
guy to get arrested 70 years
later for something he did
as a teenager? Even if he is
the biggest content, the planet.
I think the Philly cops have other shit
to worry about that movie apt pupil.
That sounds like APP people. Do
you remember that movie? Yeah.
Except this guy was a,
he wasn't,
he was in a guard tower where that
other guy was like a Rudolf Hess.
More type of guy.
Um,
I don't think it's fucked up for you to
get arrested for something that you did
in your teenage years, but like 158 but
this is the thing, he's a 17. This is the,
if, if he can't, if he came at
it like this and saying, listen,
this guy was a teenager,
all right,
when this madman took over his country,
he doesn't have a choice.
He has to join the fucking army. Um,
and everybody's like, well, you know,
you could say, no, I'm not
doing it. And then it's like,
then you get your brains blown out.
You can't just go, well fuck it.
I'm Outta here. It's 17. Where
are you going to go? The,
not only is your country
completely at war,
the entire continent is it war?
And I think it's very easy to not be 17
in the middle of fucking World War Two.
And for you to sit there and go and like,
you know what I would've done,
I would've been an angel and I would've
done this, this, this and this and this.
And it's just like,
like I can have empathy
for the situation that he
was put into, but, um, it's,
it's one of those things where it's,
I mean,
what happened there? I mean, they're
prosecuting people. I mean, I dunno.
Do you think that the 17 year old kid,
I mean he's a fucking kid.
I the person or the people that would
be very concerned about having this
person,
the rest it would be like,
all right.
You know what's hilarious is that me and
Nia just talked about this subject for
like fucking 15 minutes
and came to this great place as to
why you have to arrest this guy.
And the fucking batteries
wore out. God dammit. I know.
I told you, I told you this is just
not a, this just ain't my fucking day.
Um, so all I can do is paraphrase. Oh God,
what a fucking buzzkill
is basically Kyle, what,
what I left off saying,
it's like he got to prosecute him
because he was part of a war crime.
So you have to prosecute
him. But I, you know,
I was basically making the point that
if this kid in Philly who I don't agree
with the way he seems to be defending him,
I'm defending them the way I am.
I'm defending that 17 year old
kid in this way that everybody,
if he was to walk into it, if you,
anybody that was to wa, you know,
you guys were to walk into a bar and
you were to bring that up and you'd ask
people what they would do,
what they would've done in that situation.
Everybody's going to be captain America.
Everyone's gonna be like,
Dude, you know what?
I will die. I will go.
I would have fucking shot here the wound
phase and now we're done. We're done.
Then
type of shit. And it's
just like, you know, any,
it's very easy to be fucking sitting in
a bar drinking a fucking rolling rock
and a paint yourself out to
be this unbelievable hero
and all this shit that you
would have done.
But like a,
I think unfortunately this kid was
born at the wrong fucking time.
I don't think that, like I, I mean,
I really don't think that this,
this kid wouldn't, you know, he wouldn't,
do you think that this kid was just an
evil kid and he was like psyched to be up
in that guard tower or is he just, I
mean, who knows? Like I'm, I'm not,
and I'm not saying that, I'm not
saying that. I don't really know that.
I don't really think that it matters,
which was my point.
I feel like this person's sympathy is
misplaced. I'm not talking about him.
I'm talking about me now. Oh, it's
about, you know, I'm talking about,
I'm talking about my opinion,
which is what that you can't,
because he was 17 years old.
Chances are he wasn't,
he didn't want to do it
and he was asked to do it.
I'm saying it's 17 you're
very impressionable.
You can get talk that you can get
brain like a 30 30 35 year old person,
45 year old, 55 year old person. You know,
at that point you, you, you're,
you know, so much more about life.
Like people can't come up to you and
tell you like it's very hard, much,
very harder for,
for a much more difficult for somebody
to come up to you and try to convince you
with something that you know isn't true,
that you know is not and you can
spot crazy from a fucking mile away.
But what I was talking about,
which of course got lost was what usually,
I don't know what it is about people
who are smart and people who are like,
hey live and let live there
because of that intellect.
They're also not,
they don't choose violence
and unfortunately that's,
you need to fight fire
with fire with the like,
well violence doesn't solve anything.
It's like violence would have solved this.
Like when you were dealing with,
when they were first starting to take
over and people would choosing self
preservation rather than helping out
their neighbors is what they should have
gone out is they should have
gone out and like, I mean like,
and this is once again I'm
doing this woulda Coulda,
Shoulda Shit. Like, oh dude,
you know what I would've done?
You should have gone out there or you
should organize the people on your block.
You know, when you, if you had a Jewish
family on your block going like, look,
we're all down with, well these are
our friends. They're not taking them.
And if they come down here, you
know, we're fucking taking them out.
And if,
and if you started that movement and
you started taking them out before they
took everybody else out,
you could actually stop it.
But the thing is,
is decent people,
regular people live and let live
people are essentially not organized.
And that's the only advantage that
they had was they were walking around,
they were organized.
And then I think that people
choose the cowardly, uh,
decision of self preservation.
But I don't think self preservation
is cowardly. At 17, I think 17 I mean,
you were a boy. You're not, it's like
that Brittany Spears, not quite a woman.
You're not quite a man there near.
And all of a sudden this,
this fucking event comes along and
you get swept up into it. So, look,
if this guy was, let me,
this is what I'd say,
if this guy was 30 and he was in a
guard tower, fuck him. All right.
If you're 17 and a guard tower, you still
got to prosecute them. But like, I'm,
it's like I'm going to sit there
and be like, dude, you know what?
I would've gone to 17 when the
entire continent was at war.
I would have fucking walked to Africa
and just left it behind. Like, I mean,
I don't know what this kid,
yeah.
Uh,
I mean his, his option
was basically, uh, he,
he had to take a bullet in
his own head or go up there.
Yeah. I Dunno. I Dunno.
I'm out on this one.
I think I'm out. I mean, I
just don't feel like, I dunno,
I don't have anything really to contribute
anymore to that question other than
what I just said about there's
sympathy beam is placed. Yeah.
I can't seem to have a conversation
with you about what I'm saying.
You just keep going back to this kid.
I'm not saying that this kit,
I'm saying what I'm saying and I'm,
I'm,
I'm actually talking about how a fucking
lunatic, like Hitler comes into power.
He doesn't come into power
because he makes sense.
He comes into power because all these
other people that don't think he makes
sense.
Okay.
They choose self preservation.
Right. Okay. He's not going
after me. I'm Protestant.
It's not going to have to me. I'm
Catholic, he's not going off to me,
I'm straight and you and you end the fear
of watching your neighbors who he had
a fucking cookout with and you hear them
screaming as they're getting dragged
out of the house and you know,
you should be doing something but
you don't because of your own self
preservation. I think it's very easy for
people to hear this story and be like,
oh, the fucking nuts, you piece of
shit and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
This people as adults would choose self
preservation who would criticize what
this kid did when he was 17 that's my
point. My point is not that, that, uh,
mmm
that this is wrong, that
they're prosecuting. It's, it's,
but I also don't look at this dude who
when he was 17 who ended up in that,
that situation, like this was
somebody who was, was okay,
like clearly making decisions in his life
or even had control over the direction
of his life.
I mean,
there's a reason why you can't drink
till you're 21 it's because the level of
immaturity you have.
You think this kid can,
we had 17 has the fucking maturity
to be able to handle what's going on,
walking down the street and seeing
people hanging from, you know,
by piano wire and that type
of thing. I mean, it's, it's,
it's just another ruined life because of,
of this fucking psycho.
Okay.
Could you agree with that? Yeah, I
could see that for sure. All right.
This is way too heavy a fucking topic
to be discussed in here. So that's,
that's basically the gist of what it is.
Maybe it's this,
maybe it's just too early.
It's too heavy. I Dunno.
Maybe I'm still asleep and
I can't quite get into it.
How much after what meal during the day
can you discuss a forming former guard
tower, a Nazi guard tower,
kids after lunch conversation,
I think. Okay. All right. Well
that's the podcast for this week.
Jesus Christ, the levels just
went up. Sorry about that.
That's a podcast for this week.
Thanks for everybody for listening.
Thank you for writing in a thank you to
the Great Tony Vee for giving me that
great intro up and,
uh, uh, up in Montreal.
Thank you to the Montreal comedy festival.
Everybody who came out and,
uh, that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.